thank you
interest to report or record
no next Lord is the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of January 2023
which only seems like five minutes ago
um perhaps suppose anyone to support
those minutes
yeah eventually thank you okay and going
on to uh item four which is Matters from
Council for overgroup over over a few
and Spruce League committee
um if any
apologies
thank you thank you for that counselor
I've said okay well let's move into the
substantive parts for me too then so
item number five which is the letter of
strategy review and counselor Hardy
thank you Linda
um I'm delighted to bring forward this
report today
um the next stage on the Journey of the
Trafford Leisure strategy review the
recommendations there is also a part two
to this paper
um but as you can see the
recommendations are that the executive
um approved that Stratford leisure
Center will follow alternate Leisure
Center in the next phase of the
refurbishment program
I had the pleasure of visiting Stratford
Leisure Center today and had a good tour
around and it's fairly obvious just to
see how dated Stratford Leisure Center
is how desperately it needs and update
and how important that update and refurb
will be to the people that live in
Stratford where we know people face some
of the biggest challenges and health
inequalities so I am delighted to bring
this paper forward as you look through
the report you can see that it aligns
very very closely with our strategic
plans and priorities the Trafford moving
strategy will come to exec in March
which sets out more detail about how we
plan to get people more active and
fitter
so
um I'm delighted in 4.3 it it talks
about the urban Cricket Center we're
looking at Stratford being more of a
having a health well-being Focus much
more holistic moving away from Leisure
Services just being buildings when
people go to access the gym this is
looking at how we keep our communities
Fit and Well
um just one point to mention um because
we've had a resident contact us there is
a typo in the report
um it is going to be a six lane pool not
five I think there was a type one that
has caused some concerns with some
residents so just to clarify but it's
going to be
um so yes I will leave that with you
leader thank you thank you councilor
Harding there's a part two to this book
clearly this is after multi-million
pound investments in altering and
Leisure Center this is very good news
for for Stratford and um yes it's great
to have that clarification about the
lanes as well I'm sure some of this
would have been quite anxious about that
uh that extra Lane do we have any
questions or comments from the executive
if I go to counselor I've said first
thank you later yes
as well declare that as a user
obstructive relationship as well
actually I was actually there for the
first time today 12 weeks the session
the over session and it was able to get
back out so I was actually nice to see
there uh what I think we agree with
Council Harding and particularly the
weapons line changing there is
for a long time
outside and then obviously enjoy the
center of the people around yesterday
there but I think the proposals
contained within that to actually
realistic and much more now just
actually
activities
it's really good to be able to do that
but it is about getting those uh
connections with it with health and so
forth I think that this information I
don't know where I should something they
know I was involved in accidentally and
apparently it's when the doctors see
this and I've had my level of Fitness
helped me avoid Serious injury so I
think it's not just about what you're
doing a workout your lifestyle can
actually help yourself
in here today in that sense so I think
uh but I welcome the additional things
like the medical center being there and
so forth it'll actually make it much
more community based as well which I
think it is thank you thank you
councilman Council Patel thank you and
welcome to councilman said for leading
the active I still and just again to
welcome it I think it's a really good
news story huge
and started this process we always said
we'd follow the business case which is
what we're doing here just to welcome
the involvement of UA 92 and Lancashire
Cricket Club I know officers have spent
a great deal of time
um organizing that and working in
partnership with those two organizations
so I think that'll be a real unique
selling point for Stratford when
everybody
[Music]
okay thank you uh councilors later
remember declare an interest because I
am a instructor's counselor as an
instructor and it just because it's a
really good report I think it's
excellent news for Stratford and I used
to use it facilities but they have gone
down and who you know over the recent
years so whilst we're up and running
again I will be joining Steve and
getting fit again and but I just think
it's a really really good news thanks to
all the hard work
thank you and the figures that we see
for the usage in urmston have shown what
happens when you refer a Leisure Center
so it's very exciting prospector all
around
um okay wider questions
thank you Rita I also welcome this
report I would like my uh just to
clarify one thing I read here that
Stratford and sale Leisure centers
include the replacement of fossil fuel
gas heating system with air source heat
pumps and solar panels which I welcome
the one thing that seems to be missing
on that is culturing them and where
Ultra Moon spoilers particularly
inefficient can I just
confirm that ultimate is also having it
thank you
yeah it says yeah salt thing with a
reference in this because obviously
that's already been approved
workers
umization about work is underway that's
part of the reason
thank you for that um councilor
Blackburn
I find your leader
um could understand ask about 4.6 North
chapter general practice due to the NHS
freezing or all the state-based
decisions could ask do we have any idea
how long this will be for
and also
just because I'm
explaining what is a cool pop
which is detailed on some of the things
that the swimming outside
all Pub to improve accessibility
which I'm very interested in thank you
thank you Council of that word council
Harding thanks councilor Blackburn in
relation to how long the NHS have
decided to freeze all the states
um I can't really answer that
um we can ask questions from our NHS
colleagues and a pool pod is actually
a device which enables people to
actually access the pool there's one at
urmston and it enables people to access
the pool that may have limited Mobility
so that's what a problem is thank you
thank you uh councilor Jerome
thanks Libra
um we will welcome this uh report
um and also the carbon reduction
measures which are excellent
um also really welcome the designs to
incorp incorporate um secure cycle
storage with by car options and I just
wondered if you add a little bit more
information about about that
um it's great that it's being linked up
to the active Travel network and
connections so thank you
thank you because Harding
I think the the detail of that would be
something that will work through as we
go through the next stage where we've
got to do what can show it is as you
know in a very accessible location it's
on the 856 and it's bus route it's 500
watt from uh two trans
stations so we do like to encourage
people to come back to travel when
they're coming to the gym rather than to
buy drive them to the gym and then take
the exercise so we think having problem
with cycle revision is an important
factor
can I just add to that um it's
interesting actually I've had a couple
of emails from residents talking about
accessibility in general than people who
have disabilities and one woman had
emailed me last week and as we walked
around today we were looking at part of
the consultation just having
conversations about accessibility of
leisure escapes so I think the whole
opportunity of this refurbishment allows
us to look more broadly about how people
access Leisure facilities across the
guru okay
okay thank you and councilor but
thank you
I realize you know now that we've gone
through into this or refurbishment
program on this from the conversations
that we had in the past uh I've been
welcome this and I hope that this will
it's a critical
[Music]
development at the time scales that
follow it should be sort of kept on it
cracked up to the settlement stages so
that you know it's uh look at these
numbers
because play altering at the start is
going to be one that's going to be a
main revenue generated trying to get the
others uh to follow on
so I do welcome that and it's good that
you know you've got the uh this
modernization schemes in order to keep
it the energy efficiencies in place
one thing I just wanted to mention of
the uh the Stratford one the
it's going to have the the cricket
academy uh that are going to be helping
on that I'm just wondering how the uh
the rest of the borough the Channel's
got those kind of facilities are going
to be able to the uh for use those
facilities how they will integrated
schools or
um clubs people that want to be able to
get through like a really good level at
Cricket but they can use those
facilities as well
thank you
thanks councilor but I think the what I
would say is that the Leisure strategy
is a good new story for the whole of
traffic reading some of these Leisure
estate have not had Investments for many
years and what I think is exciting about
each of them is there is a genuine mix
of lots of activities across different
parts of the world in relation to
quickly more widely there has been
conversations about cricket being able
to conduct potentially some of the parks
and we will have conversations with our
partners our sporting Partners across
the borough because the aim is to make
sport and activity accessible to all
including things like walking tennis
walking netball with much more creative
and Innovative about what Leisure and
fitness looks like so I think there are
conversations to be had apart as as a
part of Trafford moving as well
thank you very much so this is uh part
one uh part two is to follow later in
the meeting but uh recommendations are
one to five hours set out in the report
all those in favor
thank you very much so next item is the
Longford Park Heritage fund delivery
phase approval and it's a counselor
Patel
thank you I think this is a another good
news story for the borough I'm very
pleased to present this report which
summarizes what has been a long-standing
ambition to secure the refurbishment of
Longford Park through the national
lottery Heritage fund we submitted an
outline outline building in 2019 or an
although disrupted by the covid pandemic
we have progress work with the ranger
key stakeholders to finesse plans we've
held several rounds of consultation and
secured match funding offers for a
project that will completely transform
our offer in Longford Park attached to
the report is a plan of proposals and I
would like to draw out some of the key
elements of what's being proposed
the development of a volunteer activity
and skills Hub which will benefit groups
and residents across the borough repair
and restoration of key Heritage elements
of the park improved sporting facilities
including play pitches in a BMX track
enhancements to footpaths play areas in
the modular Pence corner
there will be significant work to
promote biodiversity and restore natural
habitats including the reintroduction of
Longford Brook
there will be a two-year delivery
program of activities and events to
engage schools and residents with
activities in the park this funding will
allow us to recruit project coordinators
for this program but been particularly
helpful the project requires much
funding and much work has been done in
this area which involves external
Partners such as the environment agency
United utilities city of trees mersey
River trust as well as our own capital
and 106 funding sources we will report
back in September to September executive
on the overall funding position of this
project
like all our Parks Longford Park is much
loved by the communities it serves as
the largest park in the borough it is a
significant attraction that draws people
from a wider area
this project will secure its long-term
future encourage greater use of it
provide new Leisure opportunities
Ulster community and volunteer capacity
it will protect its Heritage and
significantly boost its environmental
sustainability I would like to thank
officers our partner agencies in the
National Lottery team who have
progressed progressed these complex
plans through what's been a challenging
time
so on the basis of what's proposed here
I'm asking except to approve the
completion of the application to be
submitted to the lottery in May
thank you councilor Patel and I
completely agree this is a very exciting
prospect for Longford Parker Park
steeped in Heritage and also a wealth of
activities available that we can only
enhance with this with this process and
thank you very much for your time on
this any questions or comments from
executive counselor answered
foreign
[Music]
it's fantastic and I mean I can't I can
put it for okay
thank you Steve you say that as a
lifelong strategic resident who's seen
much change in Longford Park and this is
looking forward to
um any other questions or comments from
the exact any wider questions uh yes
councilor Blackburn
okay thank you later could you just get
clarification
um
2.16 mentions the senior senior
community engagement officer full-time
three and a half year post and it says
10th January 23 in 4.1 it then says it's
uh from Winter 23 which I'm assuming is
later this year and also once the
foreign ends in 27 will it be volunteers
it will take over those posts or will
they are they likely to be continued
music
thank you Council thank you apologies
and that should read winter 23 for the
start of that position in terms of part
of this report and I will find it does
refer to the ongoing sort of financing
of the community space
um and the posts there they are
currently as as we speak timely limited
the posts but there is a good good deal
of work that needs to be done on how we
present the long-term plan sustainable
plan to keep for managing the community
space and potentially keeping those
posts open but for now they're time
limited and linked to the lottery thing
and they just also saw us on them 5.6 it
mentions the section 106 contributions
uh for developments within the facility
a month apart are they likely to be sort
of minimal contributions
um or are we expecting something larger
before
bringing more Revenue to to use
I don't know the answer to that
um
I could ask the question and get back to
you we will be coming back the match
funding around this is complex there's a
lot of external
um partners that we're working with as
well as internal funding that we're
relying on we're coming back if we
submit in May by September we should
know if we've been successful with the
lottery bid and we'll come back to
Executive September with a full
breakdown of the implications of that
much funding for us as an authority
thank you Council tell Richard I think
you wanted to come in at this point yeah
the the table in paragraphs I've got 5.7
it sets out the section 106 contribution
it's already received
thank you thank you very much thank you
Richard and councilor but you indicated
thank you uh it's good tool that you've
uh engaged with the local groups and
Friends through the park and I know you
touched on Heritage there which I felt
well
um with all this work that's going to go
on I think the the ryland's family was
effectively Pioneers in conservation
area is there any recognition going to
be given to them in terms of uh
um in the park as to and then their
memory of what they've done
absolutely if we're based on the
writings
contribution to the park and we're going
to be improving signage and explanations
and of the historic layout of the of the
building there so we're going to DeMark
on the throne of the rooms that would
have been there'll be a lot of
connection back to Ireland that's the
core of the Heritage story that needs to
be told
yeah thank you very much thank you and
it is such a shame that that building
went Longford hall because it was ion
Council beautiful building that
unfortunately was lost to us many years
ago now okay in terms of this report
so use that oh yes sorry counselor
so I wasn't originally intended to speak
I was sort of a comment because my
attention is being distracted by this um
map that's within the report that shows
um like the harp in glorious color
um and it's just surrounded by thousands
and thousands and thousands of houses
um not all of which are in traffic
um just back the question whether
Manchester meant to kick into this um
project at all that's not my point my
point is it clearly illustrates it just
reminded me of a map of New York really
with Central Park
um there was deep down in the center of
it and
um it's just the show the importance of
uh uh Park
um amongst so much
um a residential property
yes I I couldn't agree more and I think
that's a good way to underline this
particular agenda items so
um the recommendations are one two three
as set up in the report all those in
favor
thank you very much so our next item is
the inclusive economy delivery plan and
that is over to councilor Patel again
thank you
thank you back in February 21 the
economic shock caused by the pandemic
was becoming evident in traffic
recognizing the positive role that
Trafford council could play in the local
economy the executive at that time
approved the first inclusive economic
recovery plan to support residents of
businesses out of those difficult times
as we start 2023 the economy is still
considered to be recovering from the
covid-19 pandemic and we now face the
uncertainty created by inflation and
interest rate Rises we have a real
challenge supporting people out of
poverty and with the cost of living
crisis so it's timely therefore to
produce an updated plan that will take
account of the council's new corporate
priorities new projects initiatives and
available funding there are two elements
to this paper the first reports back on
the first recovery plan with a reg rated
summary of what we have achieved which
includes among many areas of success
securing a great a significant amount of
external funding to support our town
centers in new housing inward investment
targets Kickstart placements and great
success around our skills and training
program
the second element sets out the
objectives of the new Trafford inclusive
economy delivery plan produced as a
continuation of the recovery plan but
recognizing changing circumstances and
priorities with a much more longer term
approach to project delivery we have
identified a number of objectives under
under six areas which cover employment
skills business
Town Center regeneration Community
social value and volunteering Community
sector objectives climate change and the
green economy finally development
Frameworks these objectives have
Associated kpis and will be monitored
moving forward this plan is designed to
be proactive relatable and practical set
of objectives that will make a
difference to our businesses and on the
ground in our communities took out just
a few of these Ambitions and targets we
have around developing local Supply
chains a retail property refurbishment
Grant better coordination with gmca over
skills the realization of our social
value action plan and our carbon neutral
action plan
whilst we are in some ways at the mercy
of national and global economic forces
there is much we can focus on locally
whilst some may consider local
government a burden on our economy we
see councils as active players who can
help shape and drive Local Economic
priorities thank you
thank you uh councilor Patel and I
completely agree with all of what you've
said particularly was as a council and
how we look to support and help our
local economy and local businesses
that's very important do we have any
questions or comments from the executive
any wider questions uh councilor Jerome
thanks leader
um as part of this report on page two
and three when it does talk about carbon
reductions it does mention reducing
vehicle miles traveled on road and
traffic
um but yet this report is supporting the
building of the Carrington Link Road
um we've already been told that's
greatly the worst case scenario this
will jump from 50 million in costs to
worst case scenario 66 million and we
know when you build New Roads it tends
to create more traffic so our carbon
emissions will go up rather than down
um so I don't know how this report can
really support the building of a massive
View Road in our Borough and support our
carbon targets thank you
councilor Patel I mean just firstly this
isn't meant to
um replicate
plans around our carbon neutral
it is
um the greens May struggle to see why a
road could help generate the local
economy their residents in auctions
certainly do benefit from every possible
connection available to them to find
work and opportunity and that's
something that we're looking to afford
to the people of Carrington Parkington
too
thank you uh councilor blackberg
thank you leader the section
um strategic science developmental job
creation
um it mentions the um Trafford Park
carbon studies and I just wondered when
we get a paper on the um on the
completion of those studies
thank you council department Council
Patel it fee it will feed into a wider
Greening Trafford Park working group
um if I could ask Richard when we have
feedback on that
the executive in that
so not long to wait uh councilor Welton
the advantages that all those are the
problems that come with having a massive
great big road right through the middle
of your town
um but I was interested in the in this
report obviously we had the
disappointment of the leveling up fund
for sale
um not not happening um that's
highlighted in one section of the report
uh and but also discussing how that
related to the mayor's challenge fund
um work for us for the groups going from
sale to sale uh water park I'm just
wondering is that is the best challenge
fund
um work still likely to go ahead or is
that going to be reliant on on finding
some new funds from somewhere else
rather than delivering up
okay should I go to counselor Patel and
this isn't the report that will answer
that question so um
so I'm looking to Richard that in that
case
I think we'll come back to settlement
backwards it's a complicated uh funding
version
and then finally councilor books
Furniture uh I mean the key to an
economic delivery plan has to be holding
on to the existing businesses or
creating environment to generate more
business investment clearly you know the
the admission has been looking for some
time to make any Headway in developing a
constructive initiative to generate that
promotion close and grow the local
economy so I just wanted to say if you
do anything that the solution is like a
digital engagement to your website going
to be some kind of Panacea Business
Development or the local economy
I reject the idea that we haven't been
to support the business you've taken one
element of this business support
proposed and put a sort of a derogatory
slant on it or there's a whole wide
range of business
so that we're offering here and it's not
just within this report it's an
inclusive economy
um team work very closely with a great
deal of businesses across the borough
and through our Partnerships between
switches it'd be wonderful if we had a
business friendly government
who didn't cause the hiking of interest
rates and actually gave more help in
terms of energy costs but there we are
we have to do the best we can via our
residents and that's what we'll continue
to do so in terms of this we're going to
note the previous progress against the
plan and also approve the new Trafford
inclusive delivery plan 22 23 to 24 25
all those in favor
thank you okay moving on to agenda item
number eight at Ultraman teleport we've
previously set out why it's important
for us to take this decision forward
tonight in order to facilitate the
disposal before August 2023 in line with
our asset of community value
requirements however given the last
minute Communications we have received
and the points raised in those
Communications whilst we remain
confident in our actions in respect of
this
disposal I recognize the importance of
ensuring all Communications have been
fully considered and addressed before
progressing with the decision which has
simply not been possible since the
receipt of those Communications earlier
this evening I therefore propose to
defer this agenda item until next month
moving on to agenda item number nine Old
Trafford derelict buildings program
councilor Patel
thank you I think this is another good
news story although it's based on
um a miserable experience of poor
development in Old Trafford which I have
to say isn't the norm but when it does
happen it has a huge impact on our
communities during the early 2000s Old
Trafford experience the residential
construction boom which resulted in a
number of poor quality substandard and
inhabitable developments we have worked
with agencies for some years to progress
improvements but a number of these
developments continue to blight our
neighborhoods because many of these
developments sit within a small area of
Old Trafford they have a
disproportionate effect on communities
there in some cases leaseholders are
unable to occupy properties because the
buildings are subject to fire
prohibitory
profits and dentists content denying
them either a home or an investment
income some of these apartments have
been built off plan but have never been
completed leaving owners without any
property at all on other sites residents
continue to be affected by the
consequences of non-compliant
construction where empty where
properties are empty they may be subject
to vandalism and anti-social behavior
and require ongoing attention from the
council or Emergency Services
further we have a number of properties
that sit on the department for leveling
up and housing and communities watch
list for unsafe planning in high-rises
these buildings unlike others in GM
don't have an agreed route to securing
improvements we are setting out today an
action plan through which we will seek
to take enforceable action where
possible against the owners of these
buildings and part two we'll set this
out in more detail the message from part
one however is that we won't tolerate
unsafe and poor quality development
thank you very much councilor Patel and
I know that I'm sure many of us will
have seen some horror stories of people
living in such developments of
incredibly poor quality so I am really
pleased to see this on the agenda I'm
going to go to councilor Wright first of
all
[Music]
developments on safe
um and unacceptable and um this is a
positive move in the right direction uh
to make sure that these developments are
put right or demolished and that the uh
the the people in Belgium refers by
support of Justice the one thing I would
say is very helpful
um if the government would review the
building regulations and how robustly do
they
um they enforce these in future to um so
these sorts of things aren't allowed to
continue in future because it's the
council and we are limited as to what we
can do so it'll be very helpful if the
government institutions are about this
in the near future thank you thank you
councilor right councilor Williams
Vision to the area
um which I consider that to be a real
shame actually because there's some
absolutely stunning architecture in this
part of Trafford and you can when you do
walk around the area you get a real
sense of our industrial Heritage in the
program
um
this part of the bullet is um our
doorstep to the city center really and I
think it's got the capacity to offer an
absolutely great residential offer as
part of the new community emerges so
hopefully this will be the first step
toward fully realizing this area's
potential but in addition to that I also
just want to welcome the really
proactive enforcement work that the
council is doing in respect to building
safety in collaboration of course is
very much just buying rescue sort of
this
so it's really reassuring to see that
we're utilizing all of the options
available to us in respect of enforcing
appropriate buildings
so with that really pleased to see this
this evening and happy to support
awesome thank you
thank you very much councilor Williams
are there any other questions
um counselor books
thank you I know this plenty of actually
the the council can take and this is one
of them and it'll certainly support the
enforcement
[Music]
I also support this um
approach and action in the area I I note
the former ducksworth building and the
Trafford press a beautiful Heritage
buildings I hope they're attainments and
enhance um and brought back into use and
I look forward to this approach being
moved more wisely across traffic we have
lots of other types of death and
benefits thank you thank you very much
okay well the uh
recommendation here is to note the
report and acknowledge further
information required all those in favor
thank you very much moving on to agenda
item 10 which is the CCTV partnership
agreement and Council rights thank you
later I I hope they weren't able to
achieve time up with this one
um this should be a furnished as well
it's important report that the exact can
approve to extend our partnership with
uh Salford city council for the CCTV
control room over in the Salford Civic
Center
um having registered this site for the
last few months I've come so it's a
really really well organized and
developed system that is a very
interesting place to go for counselors
and I'm sure they've alchem anyone to
attend as long as you give them prior
notice and it is um it's run by um from
a very professional people and I'm more
than happy to I am recommended that it
continuous agreement from five years
thank you
thank you very much Council Wright are
there any questions or comments from the
executive
anything wider yes comes to new brush
yes so yeah I will welcome this too um
we did raise this in Council a while
back and I note in this report that much
of the equipment uh is coming to end of
life and that we're generating our own
network and CCTV I'm wondering if we can
use this opportunity to steer traffic
away from a kit that our security
services in the American Security
Services would consider a dubious nature
I just hope this will be maybe a moment
of consideration
Also may be part of the process Council
I knew about having had that
conversation myself thank you thank you
thank you and councilor Blackburn
thank you Elizabeth
um
partnership work
okay
and once the GM authorities they're out
um quality limits
will the uh cleaner Plum amp our hand
must be used for potential law
enforcement to actively detect crime
I can't answer that one unfortunately
councilor Blackburn Council Williams and
everything cancel it
the way it's being undertaken at a great
Manchester combined Authority level and
no decisions been made yet and at the
most eastern Geo GM quality
Administration you can see we can see
that no decision will be made without a
form of the consultation being
Undertaker and as we get any updated
thank you okay well the recommendations
are one to three are set out in the
report all those in favor
okay so we move on to the annual
Ombudsman report which I think was
originally supposed to go to exact
either in November or December last year
but has been deferred for obvious
reasons so this is the annual report and
police say in 2122 no public interest
reports were issued 10 upheld plates
were were there a number of these were
relating to previous years
um this is a report for noticing are
there any questions from the executive
anything further
councilor Blackburn
Thank you Lisa
um well I'm exciting on the back page uh
before out of the ten up healthy plates
have procedure for communication issues
can relevant training be reviewed at
least on an annual basis in order to
ensure that these dance reoccur
absolutely Council Bluff and I think
that's a really good point where we
identify patterns such as this we should
be putting in training to ensure it it
stops happening again so thank you for
that contribution any other questions
okay well this is a report for noting
all those in favor
thank you very much so we now move to
Urgent business
um of which I have known so I am now
going to move to the exclusion
resolution item 13 and once more I will
read this out in full with some
dubious Flair that the public be
excluded from this meeting during the
consideration of the remind remaining
items on the agenda because of the
likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which Falls within one or
more descriptive categories or
categories of the local government as
1972 schedule 12a are cemented by the
local government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
each such
okay
thank you very much
Alex if you tell us when we are
recording